samon play said I destroyed this
question now notice guys that's more
deception right notice that when a when
a Muslim answers answers a question he
can give the worst most ridiculous
answer anyone has ever heard ever but he
will he will boast about it as if he's
given just a completely devastating
remark why because Muslims know that
their fellow Muslims who aren't really
paying attention they're just seeing who
thumps their chest the most right
whoever thumps his chest the most and
yells the loudest and makes it sound
like I crush them that's the one who
gave the best answer even if it's the
stupidest answer anyone's ever heard
ever right so salmon Flair here says I
destroyed this question god of the Bible
started Creation with
deceive he created two naked humans and
then meet them every day and played a
poker face then he was mad when his
deception was uncovered are you a are
you even able to make sense of this it
looks like he's saying ah yeah that he
created he created Adam and Eve uh he
created Adam and Eve naked but they
didn't realize it and God's sitting
there meeting with them and don't
realize they're naked but then after the
fall after they sin they realize they're
naked and now they're mad because they
realize that uh that God had deceived
them right God had somehow man if you
were able to make sense out of that I'm
shocked that's what you got I didn't I'm
reading and I'm like that's what you got
huh okay I'm
sorry oh boy is that what he's asking
really that supposedly they were naked
and they were kept from knowing they
were naked and that's God's fa fault
because he had a well remember remember
remember right they didn't realize they
were naked yeah so he he he deceived
them into not realizing their nak now
what in now why don't you actually
explain what that what that means there
Sam before what it like before sin you
know what's amazing is that this same
story is found in chapter 7even of the
Quran it's same story start reading
chapter 7 it says the same thing that
they also came to the realization that
they were naked and Allah had to clothe
them so I don't know what he's trying to
prove but anyone reading the chapter is
quite clear what what's happening is is
that because of sin sin has corrupted
the way they view reality in other words
Genesis 3 is an excellent description of
the netic effects the effect sin has on
your mind let me give you a very bad
example what I mean you can take two
children put them in front of each other
naked and they have
no lustful desires for each other
they're in a state of Innocence they see
their nakedness as something harmless
and something good not something that is
lustful or perverted what happens to
Adam and Eve is that prior to partaking
of the tree that was forbidden them
their mind was pure their mind was was
righteous so that when they saw each
other they didn't see each other through
the corrup lens of of perverted lustful
desires they saw themselves as innocent
they saw themselves as childlike in
other words they had a childlike
innocence that was corrupted by sin so
what was innocent at one stage now
became something impure and evil because
their minds had been corrupted by sin
what we call the netic effects of sin
and this is encapsulated by what Paul
says in Titus 11:5 Paul sums it up
perfectly to the pure Titus 115 all
things are pure but to the corrupt and
unbelieving nothing is pure their very
minds and consciences corrupt so this is
what you're seeing taking place in the
garden prior to eating of the Forbidden
tree their minds were pure their minds
hadn't been corrupted everything they
saw they saw in a state of innocence and
Purity because they were bearing the
image of God but because of sin that
which was at one stage innocent now
became something perverted something
dirty something lustful because their
minds had been corrupted the reality was
the same but the way they view that
reality had now been tainted by sin
that's all you're getting from in
Genesis 3 so God creates them in a state
of childlike innocence so that they
don't they don't even they don't even
realize hey we're we're we're running
around naked here they don't see any
problem with that and then they sin then
they sin that changes that changes their
relationship with each other it changes
their relationship with God it changes
everything they realize that that now
now they're paying attention to things
like Hey we're we're naked here we're
walking around you know what's what's
going on here God brings them up God
brings this up with them hey something
has changed here why don't you explain
to me what you did and then Salmon's
players you see this is just like the
god of the Quran deceiving Muhammad
deceiving his companions deceiving
literally billions of people over the
centuries it's the it's the same thing
guys who would call this who would call
this deception right God's not deceiving
them they were in a state of childlike
innocence they were in a state where
they're not they're not thinking in
sinful terms that changed because they
did eventually sin God brings this up to
them what's Salon players's response and
you know it's just amazing that we can
say
hey deception because you're taking as
your primary uh your primary deity
someone who brags about being the best
of deceivers we point out how this in
influences the behavior of the Muslims
here uh of Muslim apologist uh of even
Muslim Prophet like Muhammad how
deception can be viewed as a good thing
we look at that and then what's the
response here the response is salmon
play's response is hey I can even
deceive some some ignorant people here
about the God of the Bible I can deceive
people I can I can I can help Allah in
his
deception and so anyway thanks samon
play and don't forget and David don't
forget Paul says it perfectly in one
verse if you guys want to know what
happened to Adam and Eve Titus 115 to
the pure all things are pure So Adam and
Eve were created in a state of Purity
innocence but to the corrupt and
unbelieving nothing is pure their very
minds and consciences are corrupt that's
exactly what happened to Adam and Eve
that's exactly what happened in a
nutshell prior to eating of the
forbidden fruit they're in a state of
Purity and innocence so even their
nakedness was something good something
pure something innocent sin messed up
all up that's all you're getting
there all right so uh thank you salmon
by way uh David there's two salmon
prayers the original salmon player says
it's not him it's someone aping his
accounts I don't know because I just saw
there St all right guys if you see fake
accounts by fake people then uh uh
moderators feel free to block them just
make sure you're you're you you are
clear that this is a someone is using a
fake account
um but obviously someone was was giving
the most horrible horrible example ever
and samon
yeah salmon play you've you've been
giving the most horrible uh responses of
anyone of from all time